tracy ann welcome to you thanks for
joining us what are you seeking to
achieve
i think the first was awareness i think
for a very long time people have felt
that
anti-jewish hate was um didn't exist
uh i think while his 48-hour rant on
twitter of non-stop
uh tweets and then his four-day uh
completion on instagram of posting
videos of jewish hate
has shown that anti-jewish hatred is
alive and kicking
and i think what we were seeking to
achieve is that if platforms like
instagram facebook
and twitter have guidelines which they
do
then they have to police all race hatred
and
you know if they're just going to be a
hate site then they should be
transparent about
it but they don't want to appear to be
that way so they have to take people
like wiley's
invective uh and very painful hate race
hate into into account
and i suppose that policing becomes more
necessary proportionate to how many
follows they have i mean i hate to
reduce that sort of level of calculation
but in a sense if this was just somebody
with
you know a handful of followers a couple
of dozen it would be it would be less
damaging he's got half a million
well i mean that's the point is you know
it's like giving a racist a megaphone
you know wiley has less the issue you
know while he hates uh jewish people
he's made that very obvious
he's compared us to the ku klux klan and
uh says
say that we control the world and we're
the most evil people that exist and
should be shot
that's painful to hear but if wiley
wants to be a racist that's fine but
what isn't fine
is if sites like twitter instagram and
facebook
give him an amplifier a megaphone if you
will
to spew that hatred out to 500 000
followers without
um holding into account i think my big
point through all of this and what so
many people agree with
is that if twitter for example wants to
be just a racehate site
and allow anything to go and it must be
transparent and say this is what we are
you can post anything here
in which case people like myself the
people that i know wouldn't choose to be
on it
but they don't want to be seen like that
they have guidelines put into place
and so they've got to treat race hate
very seriously
and remove it from half a million
followers
the home secretary pretty patel says
quote social media companies must act
much faster
to remove such appalling hatred um is it
possible to
uh offer up a sort of time frame a
workable time frame i mean clearly this
can't be done
uh in seconds minutes but you say 12
hours is clearly too long
what is a sort of workable time frame
that would leave people satisfied
i mean this this is like i said this
wasn't about you know wiley per se this
this was a
a massively influential uh man on
twitter
who went on a 48-hour hate binge
he just poured this invective out and
thousands of us reported it
to twitter and they kept coming back
saying this isn't violating our
regulations
if you call jews worse than the kkk and
say they deserve to die
i think that's violating your
regulations because
jack dorsey who has twitter put those
regulations in place
i think i'm not saying that instagram's
talking about a seven a seven day ban
what would you look for well i don't
instagram waited for four days before it
did
a ban i think the point is both
instagram
all the social media platforms if
they're going to bother to put
guidelines into place which is going to
attract people like myself and i would
assume you and others
and young people onto it they want to
have
guidelines which they have put in place
race hate is illegal
you have guidelines in place to get rid
of that race hate if
thousands of people have tweeted saying
uh in to say that this was offensive
and broke the guidelines then twitter
has to act almost instantaneously
many of those posts are still up and
they radicalize people
and it's breaking the law i think uh
you know which in a sense will be for
legal authorities to determine but in
terms of the personal cost
to this artist to wiley his management
have already dropped him
some people will say okay there is
concrete evidence that when somebody is
openly anti-semitic like like this there
are consequences
no i don't think wiley i mean while he
wasn't just openly anti-semitic he went
as i say
on a four-day binge i mean he poured
poured out
tweet after tweet video after twitter
that video after video
yes there was a real life consequence to
what happened to him
but i'm not talking about what happens
to him in real life he can be as racist
as he wants i'm talking about the
platforms that effectively gave him the
megaphone
they have to decide whether they're
going to effectively
not censor anything in which case
right-minded people will never use their
sites
or if they have guidelines in place they
have to use them look instagram will
take off pictures
of women who are breastfeeding their
babies because they deem them offensive
but they let wiley keep up and the posts
are still there
videos claiming how hateful and awful
jewish people were
if social media won't act does it not
behoove the government to do so i mean i
know
you say you know real world world
consequences and neither here are there
on one level but
there are those who feel that the
government ought to rescind
his mbe what do you say you know i think
if this
i think if this country wants to give an
award to somebody who is an extreme
uh race hate provocateur then
that's up to their conscience i mean i'm
not going to say look i
i just think you know this isn't about
wiley to me
he's a racist he's outed himself he's
proven a very good point which is
that anti-semitism exists and it exists
very very loudly
on social media platforms my my main
point of starting this whole campaign
rolling and thank you to the millions of
people that have followed suit and the
politicians
is that those platforms have to take
responsibility
not to give a megaphone if that's what
their remit is
traciannova appreciate your time thanks
a lot so much